WE'LL START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
WE KNOW THAT WE OUR QUORUM IS ON
THE WAY, SO WE'LL START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE. WHICH MEANS I CAN
BRING IT TO ORDER. WE'RE HOLDING
OUR HEARING TODAY IN ROOM 2200,
IN THE Þ STREET BUILDING. AND
THOSE MEMBERS WHO ARE ON THIS
COMMITTEE WHO ARE LISTENING TO
ME, PLEASE COME DOWN TO 2200. WE
ARE CONSIDERING AB TWO ONE. THE
SPECIAL SESSION BILL. THIS
MEASURE WAS AMENDED IN THE
SENATE FUEL SUPPLY AND PRICE
SPIKES COMMITTEE YESTERDAY, AND
WILL WILL BE ELIGIBLE FOR A DUE
PASS MOTION TODAY. BUT LET'S
ESTABLISH QUORUM. GÂY. SKINNER.
I'M HERE. SKINNER. HERE. JONES.
I'M HERE. JONES. HERE. ASHBY.
BECKER. BRADFORD. BRADFORD.
HERE. CIERTO. CIERTO. HERE.
WAHAB. ALL RIGHT, SO WE WILL
HAVE TESTIMONY TODAY ON THE
BILL. WE'LL START OF COURSE, ON
THE PRESENTERS. WOULD WE START
WITH DOV ON THE PRESENTERS OR
JUST THE BILL AUTHORS? OKAY. SO
WE'LL START WITH THE AUTHORS AND
SUPPORT FIRST AND THEN
OPPOSITION. AND THEN WE'LL HEAR
FROM DOV. AND IN TERMS OF
TIMING, WE'LL GIVE SUPPORT FIVE
MINUTES. YOU CAN DIVIDE IT UP
BETWEEN YOURSELVES AND WE'LL
GIVE OPPOSITION FIVE MINUTES.
AND REMEMBER THAT THIS IS THE
APPROPS COMMITTEE. SO WHAT WE
ARE THE TESTIMONY TODAY IS ON
THE FISCAL IMPACTS. YESTERDAY
WAS THE POLICY COMMITTEE. SO
YESTERDAY WAS ON THE POLICY
IMPACTS OF THE BILL. TODAY IS
THE FISCAL. SO AS I INDICATED,
I'LL ALLOW FOR FIVE MINUTES
TOTAL TIME FOR EACH. AND THEN
THEN AFTERWARDS WE'LL TAKE
ANYONE IN THE ROOM WHO CAN JUST
GIVE THEIR METOOS, WHICH WILL BE
THEIR NAME, AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE MEASURE. SO WE
HAVE A QUORUM SO WE CAN BEGIN,
AND WE HAVE OUR AUTHORS,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, HEART AND
ASSEMBLY MAJORITY LEADER
AGUIAR-CURRY. YOU MAY BEGIN.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. I'D LIKE
TO THANK THE MEMBERS FOR OF THIS
COMMITTEE FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB 21
TODAY. AB 21 REQUIRES PETROLEUM
REFINERIES TO RESUBMIT SUPPLY
PLANS TO THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION AHEAD OF MAINTENANCE
OR TURNAROUND EVENTS, AND GRANTS
THE CEC THE AUTHORITY TO OPEN A
FORMAL, TRANSPARENT RULEMAKING
PROCESS TO DETERMINE WHETHER
REQUIRING MINIMUM INVENTORY
LEVELS OF FUELS WILL FLATTEN
PRICE SPIKES AT THE PUMP AND
SAVE CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS MONEY.
LAST YEAR'S GAS TAX ALONE IN
SEPTEMBER 2023 COST CALIFORNIANS
AN EXTRA $2.2 BILLION AT THE
PUMP. THE ANALYSIS FOR THIS
COMMITTEE STATES THAT THERE WILL
BE UNKNOWN, POTENTIALLY
SIGNIFICANT ONE TIME COSTS FROM
THE ENERGY RESOURCES PROGRAMS
ACCOUNT TO ANALYZE WHETHER
CONSUMERS WILL BENEFIT FROM
MINIMUM LEVELS OF SUPPLY,
INVENTORIES AND UNKNOWN
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT ONGOING
COSTS FOR THE CEC TO ADMINISTER,
OVERSEE, AND ENFORCE THESE
REQUIREMENTS. THE CIVIL
PENALTIES CREATED BY AB 21 COULD
PROVIDE ONGOING REVENUE
INCREASES. THE CEC ESTIMATES
THAT THE COST OF AB 21 WOULD BE
ABSORBABLE WITHIN EXISTING
RESOURCES, BUT MAY REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING IN THE FUTURE
ONCE THE COST BENEFIT ANALYSIS
IS COMPLETE. THE BILL REQUIRES
THE CEC TO CONSULT WITH THE
LABOR AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY WHEN REQUIRING RESUPPLY
PLANS FROM REFINERIES. THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD,
LABOR AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY, AND DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS ESTIMATE
THAT ANY COSTS WOULD BE MINOR
AND ABSORBABLE. THIS MEASURE HAS
THE POTENTIAL TO SAVE
CALIFORNIANS BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ANNUALLY WHEN THEY REFUEL THEIR
VEHICLES. THIS BILL WILL HOLD
OIL COMPANIES ACCOUNTABLE FOR
RESUPPLY PLANS WHEN REFINERIES
SHUTDOWNS AND SUPPLY CHAIN
DISRUPTIONS OCCUR, ULTIMATELY
SAVING CALIFORNIANS MONEY AT
GASOLINE SALES. AB 21 IS
SUPPORTED BY SEIU, UFCW, W, UAW,
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND LEADERS,
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING THE
UNION OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS
AND CEJA, AND CONSUMER RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS. I RESPECTFULLY
URGE AN AYE VOTE. AND WITH ME IS
ASSEMBLY MAJORITY LEADER CECILIA
AGUILAR CURRY. GOOD MORNING.
OOPS. GOOD MORNING EVERYONE.
MEMBERS. THE COST THE COST PER
THE ADMINISTRATION IS ABSORBABLE
WITHIN OUR EXISTING RESOURCES.
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER JUST STATED.
MOVING FORWARD, WE WILL NEED
MORE INSPECTORS AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS TO MAKE SURE THE
PROMISES WE ARE MAKING TO OUR
REFINERY WORKERS ARE KEPT. BUT
FOR TODAY, THE BILL IS
STRAIGHTFORWARD IN THIS
COMMITTEE AND WILL SAVE
CALIFORNIANS BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
AT THE PUMP. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I VOTE. GREAT. LET'S WE
CAN HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
WITNESSES JUST DO THE ADD ON.
ALL RIGHT. SO. ALL RIGHT. THIS
WAS SO ANY OTHER ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT. YOU CAN
COME TO THE MIC AND DO YOUR ADD
ON. OKAY. SEEING NONE WE WILL
ASK THE OPPOSITION TO COME AND
GIVE THEIR PRESENTATION. SO WE
HAVE OPPOSITION HERE. DO YOU
WANT TO HAVE TWO AT THE TABLE?
OKAY. WE HAVE TWO SPOTS. NO
CHAIRS TODAY. YES, EXACTLY.
GREAT. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR.
ZACH LEARY, CHIEF LOBBYIST FOR
THE WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION. GOOD TO SEE YOU ALL
AGAIN. WANT TO JUST GO OVER KIND
OF THE THINGS WE'VE HEARD OVER
THE PAST COUPLE OF DAYS AND THEN
GET INTO THE FISCAL. I THINK A
LOT OF UNKNOWN ABOUT THIS
POLICY, A LOT OF UNKNOWN ABOUT
STORAGE CAPACITY, EXISTING FUEL
SUPPLY. ALSO IN THE ANALYSIS, A
LOT OF UNKNOWN POTENTIAL,
SIGNIFICANT COST IMPACTS AS A
RESULT OF THIS POLICY BEING
IMPLEMENTED BY THE CEC. I ALSO
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THE THINGS WE
DO KNOW. WE DO KNOW THAT THIS
POLICY COULD LIKELY RESULT IN
SUPPLY SHORTAGES AND INCREASED
COSTS. WHAT WE ALSO KNOW IS THAT
THE EXISTING PROGRAMS THAT THE
GOVERNMENT AND TAXES FEES
ACCOUNT FOR EVERY YEAR IS ABOUT
$18.4 BILLION, AND THAT'S THINGS
THAT ARE IN THE CONTROL OF THE
LEGISLATURE. WHAT WE ALSO DID
HEAR THROUGHOUT THE COURSE OF
THIS PROCEEDING IS THAT
REGARDLESS OF THIS BILL, THE CEC
CAN AND WOULD DO AN ANALYSIS ON
A RESUPPLY STORAGE MANDATE. SO
REGARDLESS OF GIVING YOUR
AUTHORITY TO THE CEC, THEY WOULD
DO THAT ANALYSIS AND COME BACK
TO YOU ANYWAY. I JUST WANT TO
MAKE IT CLEAR WE ARE
FUNDAMENTALLY OPPOSED TO THE
POLICY. WE THINK POLICIES OF THE
STATE CONTINUE TO DRIVE BUSINESS
DECISIONS ON WHETHER TO STAY, OR
WHETHER TO LEAVE, AND WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE ADMINISTRATION TO FOCUS ON
HOW TO KEEP THE EXISTING
REFINERIES YOU HAVE, BECAUSE
IT'S POLICIES LIKE AB X2-1 THAT
MAKE COMPANIES QUESTION WHETHER
YOU REALLY WANT US HERE, EVEN
THOUGH THE NEED AND DEMAND
REMAINS. FOR THESE REASONS, WE
MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE
PROPOSAL THAT WILL, IN OUR VIEW,
LIKELY INCREASE COSTS ON YOUR
CONSTITUENTS. GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. JEREMY SMITH
HERE, ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWO ONE. MANY
OF YOU WERE HERE WITH WE. I WAS
HERE WITH MANY OF YOU YESTERDAY
TALKING ABOUT OUR POLICY
CONCERNS WITH THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. I WILL TOUCH ON
SOME OF THE COST PRESSURES THAT
WE SEE. FIRST OF ALL, IN THE
ANALYSIS, IT SHOULD BE NOTED
THAT IT IS STATED FOUR TIMES
THAT THERE ARE UNKNOWN BUT
SIGNIFICANT ONE TIME AND ONGOING
COSTS, COST PRESSURES. I THINK
THAT'S APPROPRIATE TO HIGHLIGHT.
I'M SURE ALL OF YOU HAVE READ
THE ANALYSIS. IT'S A VERY GOOD
ANALYSIS. ONE OF THE LONGEST
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS ANALYSIS I'VE EVER
SEEN. IT'S A VERY, VERY GOOD
THANK YOU FOR THAT. BUT THERE
ARE COST PRESSURES, IF NOTHING
ELSE GOOD COMES FROM THIS BILL
FOR OUR MEMBERS. IT HAS
HOPEFULLY IGNITED A CONVERSATION
ABOUT CAL-OSHA. THERE IS ONE
INSPECTOR FOR EVERY 121,000
WORKERS IN THE STATE. AT CAL
OSHA AND THE ASSEMBLY, WE HEARD
SOME CONSIDERATIONS ABOUT, OH,
WE CAN HAVE CAL OSHA HELP WITH
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY. WE CAN
PUT AN INSPECTOR JUST AT EVERY
REFINERY IN CALIFORNIA. THEY
CAN'T DO THAT. I KNOW THE
DIRECTOR, THE CHIEF OF CAL OSHA.
I KNOW A LOT OF THE UPPER LEVEL
MANAGEMENT AT CAL OSHA. THEY ARE
ALL GREAT PEOPLE. THEY ARE
INDUSTRIAL HYGIENISTS. THEY ARE
PROFESSIONALLY TRAINED TO DO
SAFETY INSPECTIONS, AND THEY ARE
DOING THEIR BEST. SO I LOOK
FORWARD IN THE SPRING, HOPEFULLY
TO CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION
ABOUT HOW DO WE FIX CAL OSHA.
OREGON HAS ONE INSPECTOR FOR
EVERY 26,000 WORKERS IN THE
STATE OF WASHINGTON, HAS ONE
INSPECTOR FOR EVERY 24,000
WORKERS, AND IN 1984, OSHA HAD A
14.88 INSPECTORS FOR EVERY
MILLION WORKERS. CAL OSHA, THIS
YEAR HAS 8.2 INSPECTORS FOR
EVERY MILLION WORKERS. THERE'S A
PROBLEM AT CAL OSHA. WE CANNOT
DEPEND ON THEM TO HELP OUR
MEMBERS IN A SAFETY SITUATION,
UNFORTUNATELY. AND IF CAL-OSHA
IS ON THE JOB SITE, IT'S ALREADY
TOO LATE, UNFORTUNATELY.
SECONDLY, I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THE GAS TAX. AS THE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM WISEMAN
NOTED, BUSINESS DECISIONS ARE
BEING MADE BY THAT INDUSTRY
ABOUT WHETHER TO CONTINUE DOING
BUSINESS IN THE STATE. THE LAST
TIME I CHECKED, WE HAD OVER 25
MILLION PLUS OR MINUS REGISTERED
VEHICLES IN THE STATE. MOST OF
THOSE ARE INTERNAL COMBUSTION
ENGINES OWNED BY FAMILIES LIKE
MY MEMBERS, WHO EXPECT THOSE
CARS TO LAST A LONG TIME AND TO
THE COST OF THE BILL. SURE, THE
FISCAL COMMITTEE. THE GAS TAX IS
GOING TO START FEELING SOME
PRESSURES IF WE MAKE IT HARDER
FOR PEOPLE TO FILL UP THEIR
TANKS AND TO PROVIDE THE NEEDED
REVENUE TO THE STATE TO MAINTAIN
THE INFRASTRUCTURE. AND THEN
FINALLY, OUR MEMBERS CAREERS,
THE ECONOMIC POSITIVES THAT COME
FROM THE JOBS IN THESE
REFINERIES CANNOT BE OVERSTATED.
BETWEEN 2019 AND THIS YEAR, WE
HAD 33 MILLION WORK HOURS AT
LEAST INSIDE THE FENCE LINE OF A
REFINERY. THE ECONOMIC BENEFIT
TO LOCAL COMMUNITIES. THE STATE
GOVERNMENT IS ALMOST
UNPARALLELED IN OUR ECONOMY.
THESE PROVIDE JOBS TO HELP THE
ECONOMY. THEY HELP FAMILIES, YOU
KNOW, BUY NEW CARS, FILL UP
THEIR TANKS, SEND THEIR KIDS TO
SUMMER CAMP, ALL THE THINGS.
THESE JOBS COULD GO AWAY. THESE
JOBS COULD GO AWAY IF THE
LEGISLATURE KEEPS PUSHING THIS
INDUSTRY TO STOP BEING IN
CALIFORNIA, AND WE HAVE
THOUSANDS OF WORKERS IN THESE
REFINERIES WHO ARE GOING TO HAVE
TO FIND A PLACE TO GO WORK, AND
THAT HAS NOT BEEN CONTEMPLATED
BY THIS BILL OR ANY OF THE BILLS
THAT WE HAVE HEARD OVER THE LAST
5 OR 6 YEARS IN THIS, ON THIS
INDUSTRY. SO I WILL I WILL
COMPLETE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR THE REMINDER. I WILL JUST
SAY WE OPPOSE THIS BILL AND WE
ARE GRATEFUL TO THE COMMITTEE
AND THE POLICY COMMITTEE FOR THE
WORK THAT HAS BEEN DONE TO TRY
AND MAKE IT BETTER. BUT THERE'S
STILL MORE WORK TO BE DONE. WE
OPPOSE THE BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. OUR OPPOSITION DID GO
OVER TIME. NO PROBLEM. BUT IF
THE SUPPORT SIDE WANTS TO MAKE
ANY ADDITIONS CONSIDERING THAT
YOU KEPT TO YOUR TIME, YOU FEEL
FREE. AND THEN OTHERWISE WE'LL
HEAR FROM DOV. NO, WE'RE HERE TO
HEAR FROM DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. DO YOU
HAVE. GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR.
AND I NEED TO ASK IF THERE'S
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM WHO WANTS.
WHO IS IN OPPOSITION TO ADD
THEIR ME TO. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS.
DILLON ELLIOTT, ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTIES OF KERN, FRESNO AND THE
WESTERN PROPANE GAS ASSOCIATION.
ALL IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR.
JACKIE, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FUEL AND CONVENIENCE
ALLIANCE, RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED
MANDY ISAACS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
IN OPPOSITION. GOOD MORNING.
CHAIRMAN, CHAIR, LADY TIMOTHY
JEFFERIES. INTERNATIONAL
BROTHERHOOD OF BOILERMAKERS.
LEADERSHIP OF INTERNATIONAL VICE
PRESIDENT TOM BAUCUS, STANDING
IN OPPOSITION. GOOD MORNING,
MADAM CHAIR DAVID ROSEBURG,
IRONWORKER FOR LOCAL 378. WE'RE
OPPOSED. GOOD MORNING. TOM
HANSON, BUSINESS MANAGER, IBEW
LOCAL 302. WE ARE OPPOSED. HOW
ARE YOU GUYS DOING? GOOD
MORNING. I'M FRANCISCO YANEZ AND
WITH LOCAL 378 IRONWORKERS
ORGANIZER AND I OPPOSE. GOOD
MORNING RACHEL SHOEMAKER WITH
IBEW 302 ELECTRICAL WORKERS IN
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY. WE OPPOSE.
GOOD MORNING, MARTIN RODRIGUEZ
IRONWORKERS 433 LOS ANGELES TRI
COUNTY BUILDING TRADES
PRESIDENT. WE OPPOSE. GOOD
MORNING, RENEE PALACIOS,
BUSINESS AGENT, IRONWORKERS
LOCAL 433. WE OPPOSE. GOOD
MORNING, JAY ROJO WITH THE
BOILERMAKERS LOCAL 92. WE COVER
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA, SOUTHERN
NEVADA, AND WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING, RANDY THOMAS,
BOILERMAKERS LOCAL 549, NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. AND NORTHERN NEVADA.
AND WE OPPOSE. GOOD MORNING,
ROBERT GONZALEZ OF THE
BOILERMAKERS LOCAL 92, LOS
ANGELES, CALIFORNIA. WE OPPOSE.
GREAT. ANY OTHERS? ALL RIGHT.
SEEING NONE. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS, CHRISTIAN BELTRAN WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I'LL
KEEP MY REMARKS BRIEF AS I'M
HERE TO PROVIDE A PRELIMINARY
FISCAL OVERVIEW OF THE CURRENT
VERSION OF AB 21, AS AMENDED
TODAY. SO ALTHOUGH FINANCE DOES
NOT HAVE AN OFFICIAL POSITION ON
THE BILL, FINANCE ESTIMATES THE
COST FOR THE ENERGY COMMISSION
TO BE ABSORBABLE IN THE NEAR
TERM TO IMPLEMENT THE ENHANCED
EXISTING STATUTES AND NEW
AUTHORITY PROVIDED TO THE
RELEVANT AGENCIES IN THE CURRENT
VERSION OF THE BILL.
SPECIFICALLY, WE BELIEVE THE
ENERGY COMMISSION COULD
INITIALLY REDIRECT CURRENT
RESOURCES AND STAFF TO MEET SOME
OF THE NEW REQUIREMENTS.
HOWEVER, IT IS POSSIBLE THAT
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES MAY BE
NEEDED ONCE THE FULL SCOPE OF
THE REGULATORY ANALYZES AND
ACTIVITIES ARE KNOWN AND BETTER
QUANTIFIED. FINANCE ALSO NOTES
THAT THE COST OF IMPLEMENTATION
FOR THE STATE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD, LABOR AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY, AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS ARE EXPECTED TO BE
MINOR AND ABSORBABLE. THANK YOU,
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
FISCAL QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE.
AND TO THE EXTENT I DON'T KNOW
THE ANSWER, WE ALSO HAVE SOME
OTHER REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION WHO ARE HERE
TODAY TO TACKLE THEM. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. I ACTUALLY HAVE A
COUPLE QUESTIONS AND I'LL SEE IF
ANYBODY ON THE DAIS DOES SO.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, THERE'S
BEEN REFERENCE TO THE A, A SMALL
NUMBER OF OSHA WORKERS PER JOB
IN CALIFORNIA. MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THOSE FIGURES THAT WERE CITED
IS THE ARE WHO IS CURRENTLY
EMPLOYED. OSHA CURRENTLY HAS A
LARGE VACANCY RATE IS THAT
CORRECT? WE DO HAVE DATA BEHIND
THOSE VACANCY RATES AND HAPPY TO
PROVIDE THOSE TO YOU. BUT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS, YES, THERE ARE
SOME VACANCIES IN OSHA AND OSHA
IS FUNDED. THE BUDGET WE
APPROVED DOES HAVE THE FUNDING
FOR THEM TO FILL THOSE POSITIONS.
IS THAT CORRECT? WE DO HAVE
CURRENT FUNDING TO FILL VACANT
POSITIONS. BUT JUST AS A
REMINDER, WE ALSO DID IMPLEMENT
A CONTROL SECTION THAT AIMS TO
REDUCE ON A STATEWIDE LEVEL,
10,000 POSITIONS ACROSS THE
STATE. TO THE EXTENT HOW MUCH
THAT IMPACTS OSHA IS STILL
UNKNOWN AT THIS POINT. SO THE
LEGISLATURE IN TERMS OF THAT
PARTICULAR ANSWER, IF IT IN THIS
COMING YEAR WANTS TO GIVE SOME
ATTENTION TO OSHA, IT COULD IT
COULD EITHER INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF POSITIONS ALLOCATED, WHICH
WOULD BE A BUDGET ACTION OR
EXEMPT THEM FROM THAT PARTICULAR
ACTION TO ENSURE THAT THE
VACANCIES GET FILLED. CORRECT.
OF COURSE, THE LEGISLATURE HAS
THE ABILITY TO CHANGE THAT IN
THE UPCOMING BUDGET CYCLE. OKAY.
AND THEN IN TERMS OF PARTICULAR,
THE REFINERY INSPECTION TYPE OF
POSITION, THERE WERE SOME
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS IN THAT
SPACE AT IT. IT WAS A GOOD
NUMBER OF YEARS AGO. I THINK IT
WAS IN THOSE WERE ADDED
BUDGETARILY IN 2014 AND IN MY
TRACKING OF THE BUDGET, THOSE
WERE NEVER REMOVED. WERE IS THAT
IS THAT AN ACCURATE STATEMENT? I
WOULD HAVE TO VERIFY THAT
STATEMENT WITH MY FOLKS. I DON'T
BELIEVE WE HAVE REPRESENTATION
FOR THAT ANSWER HERE TODAY, BUT
I CAN CERTAINLY TAKE THAT BACK.
AND GET AN ANSWER FOR YOU. WELL,
THAT WOULD BE GREAT BECAUSE
THESE WERE SPECIFIC PEOPLE THAT
WERE SPECIFICALLY TRAINED IN
BEING ABLE TO DO REFINERY
INSPECTIONS AROUND THE WHOLE
TURNOVERS AND PROCESS MANAGEMENT.
BUT AS FAR AS I INDICATED, AND I
DID SERVE ON THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE FOR MOST OF THE YEAR
SINCE THEN, THEY WERE NEVER
ELIMINATED. OKAY. LET ME SEE IF
THERE'S ANY OTHER QUESTIONS ON
THE DÍAS. YES. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR. I APPRECIATE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE BEING
HERE, BUT IS THERE A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE ENERGY
COMMISSION HERE ALSO WITH IT?
YES, VICE CHAIR SILVA IS IN THE
AUDIENCE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS,
BE POSSIBLE TO COME FORWARD.
CERTAINLY A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS.
YOU CAN COME RIGHT HERE. DO YOU
WANT TO COME HERE? YOU CAN GO.
YEAH. GO AHEAD. THANK YOU.
YESTERDAY. YOU CAN DO IT FROM
HERE. THERE WAS A LOT OF
CONVERSATION WITH THE INDUSTRY,
AND I KNOW THAT YOU'RE LEARNING
ABOUT THE COMPLEX ISSUE AND THE
NATURE OF THIS INDUSTRY. CAN YOU
TELL US WHAT HAS BEEN LEARNED
FROM THEM? AND MAYBE SOME THINGS
THAT YOU DIDN'T KNOW BEFORE AS A
RESULT OF THIS PROPOSAL COMING
FORWARD? YEAH. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. I THINK THE BIGGEST
LEARNING FROM US IS REALLY
UNDERSTANDING HOW THE OVERALL
LIQUIDITY FLOWS IN THE MARKET
AND REALLY UNDERSTANDING THE
AUTONOMY, SORRY, THE ANATOMY OF
THE PRICE SPIKES. SO ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS WE HAD, YOU KNOW, FROM
THE LEGISLATURE, RIGHT AFTER THE
PRICE SPIKES OF 2022 WAS WHAT
WAS THE REASON. AND WE DIDN'T
HAVE THE DATA TO CLEARLY ANSWER
THAT QUESTION. AND I THINK THE
BIGGEST FINDINGS FOR US IS
REALLY, YOU KNOW, THANKS TO THE
LEGISLATURE, THE SB ONE TWO GAVE
US A LOT OF DATA TRANSPARENCY
AND BASICALLY WE NOW UNDERSTAND
AND PRETTY INVALUABLE
INFORMATION ON WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
THE LIQUIDITY IN THE MARKET GOES
DOWN AND HOW IT RESULTS IN A
PRICE SPIKE. SO DO YOU THINK
THAT YOUR COMMISSION HAS A FULL
UNDERSTANDING OF THAT DATA AND
IS ABLE TO MAKE APPROPRIATE
DECISIONS BASED ON THAT, ON THAT
NEW KNOWLEDGE? I THINK THE I
WOULD SAY WE WOULD NEVER BE DONE
LEARNING. SO WE HAVE GOOD
INFORMATION TODAY AS THE
INDUSTRY COLLEAGUES AT THE
ASSEMBLY TESTIFIED, IT'S PRETTY
COMPLEX AND I WOULD NEVER
UNDERMINE THE COMPLEXITY OF THE
INDUSTRY OR THE OPERATIONS. BUT
WE THINK ABOUT THAT IN
THRESHOLDS OF KNOWLEDGE THAT WE
GAIN. AND I THINK THE THRESHOLD
OF KNOWLEDGE WE HAVE REALLY
ARTICULATES THE IMPORTANCE OF
THE NEXT STEP. OKAY. ONE OF THE
CONCERNS I HAD YESTERDAY IS
WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION SAID IN THE HEARING
THAT THE SEC HAS NOT RESPONDED
TO THEIR COMMENT LETTERS ON SB
ONE TWO. IS THERE A REASON WHY
YOU HAVEN'T THE COMMISSION
HASN'T GOTTEN BACK TO THEM ON
THEIR COMMENT LETTERS? NO, I
THINK WE'VE RESPONDED YESTERDAY.
THERE WERE SPECIFIC QUESTIONS ON
THREE RULEMAKING PROCESSES THAT
WERE DENIED. AND MOST OF THE
COMMENTS THAT WISPER HAS
PROVIDED USUALLY MAKE IT INTO
OUR REPORTS. SO AS AS FAR AS THE
RULEMAKINGS THREE WERE DENIED.
AND AS WE MENTIONED YESTERDAY,
THE DENIAL OF THE THREE WERE ON
PROCEDURAL GROUNDS. BUT ALSO IT
WAS DIRECTLY INTERSECTING WITH
THE PREVIOUS SPECIAL SESSION.
OKAY. I APPRECIATE THAT THE
MAYBE SOME SPECIFIC QUESTIONS TO
THE COST OF THIS BILL, THE
ASSEMBLY PETRIE-NORRIS
ASSEMBLYWOMAN PETRI NORRIS SAID
IN A HEARING ON THE FLOOR THAT
THE CEC CAN CONVINCED HER THAT
$50 MILLION AND THAT AVOIDING
ONE PRICE, ONE PRICE SPIKE WOULD
SAVE 2 BILLION ANNUALLY. WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT IT WILL COST.
PRIMARILY BECAUSE THIS
REGULATION HAS NOT BEEN WRITTEN
YET. WHAT DO WE KNOW? WHAT DO WE
KNOW IS CEC HAS NO IDEA ON HOW
MUCH IT WILL REALLY COST. SO LET
ME GO THROUGH SOME SOME POINTS
HERE, SOME HERE'S SOME VARIABLES
THAT CC MAY NOT BE CONSIDERING
IN THEIR CALCULATIONS FOR
CONSUMER COSTS. DAYS ARE
REQUIRED. INVENTORY IT IS IT ONE
DAY OR 15 DAYS? THE BILL IS NOT
SPECIFIC AND THIS WILL TIE UP
WORKING CAPITAL COSTS.
INTRODUCTION OF A NEW TRADING
MECHANISM. THIS IS SIMILAR TO A
CAP AND TRADE AND THE LCFS WHICH
WE KNOW COSTS WILL BE
ASSOCIATED. SUPPLY SHORTAGE. TO
BUILD THE INVENTORY, A REFINER
WOULD HAVE TO WITHHOLD SUPPLY
FROM THE MARKET. THIS WILL
CREATE ARTIFICIAL SHORTAGES.
WHAT IS THE COST IMPACT THERE
AND GASOLINE PRODUCTION
SLOWDOWN? FEELING THE HEEL OF
THE TANK WILL MAKE IT MORE
DIFFICULT TO PRODUCE MORE
PRODUCT AND BLENDING COMPONENTS.
THIS REQUIREMENT WILL NOW CREATE
A PINCH POINT IN THE REFINING
PROCESS THAT MAY ACTUALLY SLOW
DOWN. GETTING GASOLINE TO THE
MARKET. WHAT WILL WHAT IMPACT
WILL THESE ISSUES HAVE ON THE
PRICE OF GASOLINE AT THE PUMP?
THAT AS DOF AND WHISPER HAS
MENTIONED, IS GOING TO DRIVE THE
COST OF GASOLINE AT THE PUMP TO
OUR CONSTITUENTS? YEAH,
ABSOLUTELY. SENATOR, AGAIN,
THANK YOU FOR THAT LINE OF
QUESTIONING. JUST THERE. I WANT
TO KIND OF SPLIT THIS INTO A FEW
DIFFERENT WAYS OF THINKING. SO I
THINK THE DOF HAS BEEN TALKING
ABOUT THE ADMINISTRATIVE COST OF
THE CEC. SO I'LL PUT THAT ASIDE
FOR A SECOND AND FIRST KIND OF
ESTIMATE THE TOTALITY OF THE
CONSUMER BURDEN. AND SO THE
CONSUMER BURDEN, BOTH THE ENERGY
COMMISSION AND DPMO HAVE DONE
OUR OWN ANALYSIS. AND JUST JUST
FOR THE RECORD HERE, AND WE SAID
IT IN THE ASSEMBLY, DPMO IS AN
INDEPENDENT ENTITY AND SO WHILE
THEY ARE A COLLABORATIVE STATE
AGENCY, WE WILL TAKE THEIR INPUT
INTO OUR DOCKET AS ANYBODY ELSE
AND WOULD VERIFY THEIR ANALYSIS.
BUT BETWEEN THE CEC AND DPMO, WE
HAVE COST ESTIMATES BETWEEN 1 TO
$2 BILLION OF WHAT HAS BEEN
INCREMENTALLY PAID BY THE
CONSUMERS AT THE PUMP. AND I
JUST WANT TO, FOR THE RECORD,
ALSO STATE THAT THOSE COSTS DO
NOT INCLUDE THE COSTS FROM CRUDE
OIL OR THE TAX AND FEES. SO WE
ELIMINATED THEM AS A PART OF
THAT. SO WE'RE LOOKING AT 1 TO 2
MILLION, 2 BILLION POTENTIALLY
COST REDUCTIONS AT THE PUMP.
THEN THE QUESTION OF, YOU KNOW,
WHAT WOULD WHAT WOULD COST THAT.
SO YOU'VE ASKED A SERIES OF
QUESTIONS THERE. AND I IF YOU'RE
OKAY, I WILL TAKE THE TIME TO
ANSWER THEM. AND IF I NEED TO
RESTATE IF I COULD JUST
INTERRUPT FOR ONE SECOND AND
SENATOR JONES, PLEASE, YOU CAN
CONTINUE YOUR QUESTIONS. BUT I
JUST WANTED TO BE CLEAR THAT THE
CHARGE OF THE PROPS COMMITTEE IS
THE ASSESSMENT OF THE COST TO
THE STATE FOR IMPLEMENTATION AND
WHETHER WHETHER WE THINK THIS IS
GOOD OR NOT. THE LEGISLATURE HAS
NOT GIVEN ANY PARTICULAR
COMMITTEE OR ENTITY THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO DO THOSE
CONSUMER, THE IMPACT ON THE
CONSUMER. SO YOU CAN CONTINUE
THE QUESTIONS. BUT I WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THAT JUST TO CLARIFY
THAT THAT IS REALLY NOT OUR
JURISDICTION. THANK YOU. AND I
APPRECIATE THAT. AND IN ADDITION
TO THE CONSUMERS, OBVIOUSLY I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT THE STATE COSTS
ON THIS BILL AS WELL BECAUSE THE
STATE BUYS A LOT OF GASOLINE,
YOU KNOW, TO FUEL ALL OF ITS
VEHICLES. SO THERE IS A STATE
COST. IT'S GOING TO BE AS A
RESULT OF THIS BILL IS ALSO. SO
THANK YOU. YEAH. IF YOU WANT TO
TAKE THOSE IN HOWEVER ORDER YOU
WOULD LIKE TO THAT'D BE GREAT.
YEAH. SO JUST KIND OF THEN AS I
JUST MENTIONED, THE COST AT THE
PUMP HAS BEEN PRELIMINARILY
ESTABLISHED BETWEEN 1 TO 2
BILLION, BASED ON THE ANALYSIS
BETWEEN CÁC AND DPMO. AND THOSE
ANALYSIS WILL CONTINUE TO BE
REFINED IN FOR EACH YEAR. AND
THIS IS JUST FOR 2023. 2022 WAS
HIGHER. AND THE DOWNSTREAM
IMPACTS OF HIGHER COSTS ON THE
ECONOMY IS STILL TO BE
INVESTIGATED AND ESTIMATED. AS
SENATOR, YOU WOULD IMAGINE, THE
HIGHER PRICE AT THE PUMP WILL
TRANSLATE TO CONSUMER PRODUCTS
DOWNSTREAM. SO THAT'S SOMETHING.
SO WE WOULD YOU KNOW, COUCH IT
BETWEEN 1 TO 2 BILLION AT THIS
POINT. PRELIMINARILY. AND IN
TERMS OF PROVIDING A SOLUTION TO
MITIGATE THAT, THIS IS WHERE THE
15 DAYS THAT YOU MENTIONED,
AGAIN, FOR THE RECORD, AS WE
STATED YESTERDAY AND IN THE
ASSEMBLY HEARING, YOU KNOW, WE
LOOK AT 15 DAYS, IS NOT A MAGIC
NUMBER. IT JUST SEEMS TO APPEAR
THAT WHEN 15 DAYS WORTH OF
SUPPLY IS IN THE MARKET, THE
PRICE SPIKES, YOU KNOW, DON'T
DON'T HAPPEN ONCE YOU, YOU KNOW,
DIP BELOW THAT. THE PRICE SPIKES
BEGIN TO HAPPEN. SO THE TASK AS
WE PERCEIVE FROM FROM THE
LEGISLATURE, IF THIS WERE TO
PASS, IS TO LOOK AT EVERYTHING
WE CAN DO TO BE CLOSER TO THAT
NUMBER. AND THE WORST THAT THAT
IT HAS DIPPED DOWN IN 2022 WAS
ONLY 12.5. IT NEVER GOT DOWN TO
ZERO. SO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
CUSHION AT THE MAXIMUM OF TWO
AND A HALF DAYS WORTH OF SUPPLY.
RIGHT. THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT. SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT TWO
AND A HALF DAYS WORTH OF SUPPLY,
THAT'S ABOUT 100 MILLION
GALLONS. WHEN WE TALK ABOUT 100
MILLION GALLONS, YOU KNOW, I BUY
AND I SELL AND I LOSE ABOUT
$0.20 ON THE MARKET, ASSUMING
THE EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE IS
WHAT WE'RE GOING TO USE. YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT 20 TO $25 MILLION.
SO FOR 20 TO $25 MILLION WORTH
OF SUPPLY, YOU COULD POTENTIALLY
ELIMINATE THE BILLION TO 2
BILLION. NOW, THERE ARE A LOT OF
OTHER QUESTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
RAISED IN TERMS OF
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS AND OTHER
PIECES. AND THAT'S THE WHOLE
POINT OF THE RULEMAKING, WOULD
BE TO INVESTIGATE THEM
THOROUGHLY AND WITHIN THE
CONSTRAINTS AND THE GUARDRAILS
THAT THE LEGISLATURE IMPOSES AND
THE CÁC, IF WE DEEM THAT
ULTIMATELY THIS IS NOT
IMPLEMENTABLE WITHOUT
SIGNIFICANT COSTS, WE WOULD NOT
GO FORWARD WITH THE RULEMAKING.
I THINK THAT'S AN INTERESTING
POINT OF THE BILL ALSO. BUT
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THAT UP.
MR. LEARY WAS ASKING FOR
ATTENTION. CAN I ASK HIM TO
RESPOND? HE HAD A COMMENT TO
RESPOND AND THEN? AND THEN I'M
DONE. YOU MAY ASK HIM YES
QUESTIONS. MR. LEARY. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. I APPRECIATE THE
ABILITY TO RESPOND. I THINK YOU
KNOW, PART OF THE QUESTION AND
THE UNKNOWN OF THIS BILL IS
WHERE IS THAT SUPPLY? WHERE IS
THAT CAPACITY? WHAT IS THE COST
GOING TO BE TO IMPLEMENT A
POLICY LIKE THAT, TO HOLD 2 OR
15 DAYS OF SUPPLY? YOU'RE
HOLDING THAT BACK FROM THE
MARKET. THERE'S GOING TO BE A
DOWNSTREAM IMPACT TO CONSUMERS
THAT THOSE VARIABLES ARE VERY
IMPORTANT THROUGHOUT THE
RULEMAKING PROCESS TO BE
ANALYZED THOROUGHLY, BECAUSE THE
BILL IS VERY SPECIFIC. AND IN
LOOKING AT THE ANNUAL COST
SAVINGS TO CONSUMERS, NOT THE
EVERYDAY COST SAVINGS TO
CONSUMERS. SO IF YOUR BASELINE
IS GOING TO BE 2023 AND NO PRICE
SPIKE HAPPENS, AND BUT YOU'VE
NOW INCREASED COSTS ON
CONSUMERS, THE MATH IS JUST NOT
WORKING OUT. SO APPRECIATE YOU
HIGHLIGHTING THOSE SENATOR. AND
THOSE ARE SOME OF THE UNKNOWNS.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. THANK YOU.
MR. I APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. LET ME SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE SENATOR SATO OR YES,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SO IF THE
COSTS ARE ABSORBABLE AND MINIMAL
AND ABSORBABLE, THEN WHY ARE WE
HERE? OBVIOUSLY THEY'RE NOT. SO
WHAT I HEARD FROM OUR DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE WAS THAT THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE GOING TO BE IN, IN
CHARGED WITH FIGURING THIS OUT
ARE JUST GOING TO GET MOVED OVER
FROM SOMETHING ELSE THAT THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE FIGURING OUT AND
USED HERE. SO, SO FROM AN
ADMINISTRATIVE COST, I WOULD
LIKE TO KNOW WHAT THE MAN HOURS
ARE FOR THAT. WHO'S GOING TO BE
SWITCHED? NOT SPECIFICALLY WHO,
BUT HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
BE SWITCHED OVER SO THAT THEY
CAN WORK ON THIS, WHAT
DEPARTMENT THEY WORK ON, OR ARE
THEY'RE ALL IN CEC. SO THERE'S A
THERE'S A COST FOR THAT LABOR.
AND IF IT GETS SHIFTED OVER
HERE, WE CAN'T WE CAN'T SAY,
WELL, WE KIND OF BORROWED IT
FROM SOMEBODY AND WE'RE NOT
GOING TO COUNT IT. SO THERE IS A
COST FOR THE ADMINISTRATION OF
JUST SETTING THIS UP. AND THEN
WE CAN TALK ABOUT THE OTHER
PART. SENATOR SARAH, THANK YOU
FOR SORRY. I APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION SPECIFICALLY TO YOUR
POINT ABOUT REDIRECTING OF
RESOURCE. IT IS A VERY COMMON
TACTIC THAT MANY DEPARTMENTS AND
STATE ENTITIES DO IN ORDER TO
TEMPORARILY BE ABLE TO IMPLEMENT
LAWS THAT ARE PASSED BY THE
LEGISLATURE, TO THE EXTENT THAT
THAT DOES DRIVE COSTS, IS
ANOTHER QUESTION, AND IS USUALLY
TYPICALLY APPROVED BY THE
LEGISLATURE THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCESS. THE ADMINISTRATION
ALWAYS DOES OUR VERY BEST TO
IMPLEMENT THESE LAWS, TO THE
EXTENT THAT IT'S FISCALLY
PRUDENT, AND WE'RE ABLE TO
MAINTAIN AND NOT ASK FOR
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES. SO TO THE
POINT THAT I MADE EARLIER IN MY
OPENING REMARKS ABOUT
REDIRECTING RESOURCES THAT WOULD
BE OUR GOAL WORKING WITH THE CEC
TO REDIRECT SOME OF THEIR
EXISTING RESOURCES. I DON'T HAVE
THE SPECIFIC UNITS OR DIVISIONS
THAT THEY WOULD REDIRECT FROM AT
THIS POINT IN TIME, BUT WHAT I
CAN TELL YOU IS THAT THE PURPOSE
OF REDIRECTING IS TO MAINTAIN
OUR CURRENT BUDGET POSITION.
WHICH OF COURSE IS NOT AS
NECESSARILY NICE RIGHT NOW AS WE
WOULD LIKE IT TO BE. BUT THAT
IS, OF COURSE, TRYING TO
EXERCISE GOOD FISCAL PRUDENCE.
RIGHT? I UNDERSTAND THAT I DO,
BUT THERE'S A COST TO THAT. THAT
MEANS THIS PROGRAM IS ABSORBING
A COST THAT WAS BEING BEING
GIVEN TO ANOTHER PROJECT. SO IF
YOU'RE NOT SPENDING IT ON THAT
PROJECT ANYMORE, WHAT ARE WE
SPENDING ON THIS PROJECT THAT
COST? DO WE. NO, NOT AT THIS
POINT. WE HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO
IDEA. NOT NOT AT THIS POINT. SO
ONGOING COSTS A YEARLY COST.
THERE HAS TO BE SOME COST
INVOLVED IN ADMINISTERING AND
MONITORING AND FINING AND
ENFORCEMENT ALL OF THOSE THINGS
AND SOME OF THE COSTS WE TALKED
ABOUT, WE DON'T KNOW YET BECAUSE
THEY DON'T KNOW IF THEY'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO HIRE A BUNCH OF OSHA
PEOPLE. DO THEY HAVE ANY
ESTIMATE OF THOSE? BECAUSE I
HEARD ONE ESTIMATE FROM ONE OF
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS WAS $50
MILLION. IS THAT SOMETHING THAT
WE HAVE NO IDEA ABOUT THAT
EITHER THE ADMINISTRATION IS
PROJECTING IT TO BE, AGAIN MINOR
AND ABSORBABLE AT THIS POINT. SO
THAT IS THE BEST INFORMATION.
THE ONGOING COSTS ARE GOING TO
BE MINOR AND ABSORBABLE FOR DER.
OKAY. AND AS WELL AS THE STATE
AIR RESOURCES BOARD AND THE
LABOR AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY, WE'RE EXPECTING THOSE TO
BE ABSORBABLE AND MINOR. AND
THEN FOR THE CEC, WE DO BELIEVE
THAT THERE COULD BE POTENTIAL
COST PRESSURES IN THE OUT YEARS
ONCE WE UNDERSTAND THE FULL
REGULATORY SCHEME AND PROCESS
THAT THEY WILL HAVE TO GO
THROUGH AS PUT FORTH IN THE
BILL. ALL RIGHT. SO BECAUSE
THERE'S OTHER COSTS TOO, AND
SOME OF IT IS RELATED TO WHAT
YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT, THE $2
BILLION THING, THAT FIGURE YOU
GUYS KEEP THROWING THAT FIGURE
OUT. AND IT'S KIND OF LIKE USING
ALGEBRA WHEN YOU NEED CALCULUS.
AND THERE ARE SO MANY OTHER
FACTORS THAT DRIVE THOSE TYPE OF
PRICE SPIKES. THE GLOBAL MARKET,
IF SOMETHING HAPPENS IN THE
MIDDLE EAST, I CAN TELL YOU IF
SOMETHING HAPPENS IN THE MIDDLE
EAST, OIL GETS SHUT DOWN. THE
FIRST THING THAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN IS A PRICE SPIKE HERE,
PROBABLY WITHIN THE WEEK WE GET
A PRICE SPIKE AND NO AMOUNT. AND
THE PREMISE OF THIS IS SOMEHOW
THAT WE'RE GOING TO STORE SOME
OIL IN OUR STORE, SOME GASOLINE
IN CALIFORNIA, IT'S GOING TO
OFFSET THIS THING. AND THAT
EQUALS $2 BILLION. THAT'S NOT AN
ACTUAL COST. THE ADDITIONAL PART
OF THIS COST ANALYSIS NEEDS TO
BE, WELL, WHAT HAPPENS IF THIS
TYPE OF A PROGRAM DRIVES THEM
OUT AND NOW WE HAVE LESS PRODUCT,
LESS TAX MONEY. BECAUSE REMEMBER
WE $18 BILLION. THAT'S WHAT WE
COLLECT EVERY YEAR IN TAX AND
FEES FOR EVERY GALLON OF GAS. WE
ALL GO BY. WHAT HAPPENS THAT
THERE'S A COST FACTOR THERE TOO.
SO WE HAVEN'T ANALYZED ANY OF
THOSE COSTS. WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE ADMINISTRATIVE COST IS. WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE ONGOING COST
IS. BUT WE'RE GOING TO SIT HERE
IN APPROPRIATIONS AND GIVE YOU
THE GREEN LIGHT TO GO DO IT. SO
I'M PROBABLY NOT GOING TO GIVE
YOU THE GREEN LIGHT, BUT IT
DOESN'T REALLY MATTER IN THIS
LEGISLATURE. BUT YEAH, THAT'S MY
CONCERN IS WE HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO
IDEA WHAT THIS IS GOING TO COST.
AND THERE IS POTENTIALLY A HUGE
FUTURE COST. AND WE'RE NOT EVEN
WE HAVE NO IDEA WHAT IT IS
THAT'S NOT RESPONSIBLE. THAT'S.
EXACTLY RIGHT. SENATOR BRADFORD.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. AND MY
QUESTION IS FOR PRETTY MUCH
ALONG THE SAME LINES OF SENATOR
CHIRCO, I'M REALLY CONCERNED
WITH BEING MINOR AND ABSORBABLE
WHEN JUST LAST MONTH WE SAW
DOZENS OF BILLS THAT DIDN'T HAVE
NOWHERE NEAR THIS PRICE TAG
HAILED AND APPROACHED OR VETOED
BY THE GOVERNOR. BUT NOW, BASED
ON MY READING OF THIS, THIS
COULD EASILY BE NORTH OF $6
MILLION A YEAR. ONGOING COSTS TO
STAND THIS PROGRAM UP. SO HOW IS
THAT CONSIDERED MINOR AND
ABSORBABLE? AGAIN, MY COMMENTS
WERE FOCUSED ON THE NEAR TERM.
SENATOR BRADFORD SO APPRECIATE
DEFINITELY THE CONCERN THAT YOU
HAVE IN TERMS OF THE POTENTIAL
COSTS IN THE OUT YEARS THAT WE
MAY SEE COST MATERIALIZE. Ã CÁC
IS AGAIN FUNDED BY EPA, WHICH IS
CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT IS A
CHALLENGE FOR THE BUDGET
PROCESS, AND WE WOULD LOOK TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ON MAKING SURE THAT
EPA IS SOLVENT IN THE UPCOMING
BUDGET CYCLE AND FUTURE BUDGET
CYCLES, BUT TO THE EXTENT THAT
THESE COSTS DO MATERIALIZE IN
THE OUT YEARS IS CERTAINLY OPEN
AND WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
IN THE FUTURE TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE ABLE TO IMPLEMENT THIS
BILL TO THE EXTENT THAT IT IS
HIGHLIGHTED IN THE PROVISIONS.
WELL, IT SAYS YOU'RE REQUESTING
3.8 MILLION JUST FOR THE FIRST
YEAR OF EPA. I BELIEVE THAT
THAT'S ON SB ONE, WHICH IS PART
OF THIS. BUT, RIGHT, THAT WAS
LAST YEAR AND THAT HAS ALREADY
BEEN APPROVED. BUT AGAIN, THOSE
COSTS WILL ONLY GROW. THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO DIMINISH AT ALL. SO
I'M JUST TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
HOW IT WOULD BE ANY LESS FOR
THIS MEASURE. I CANNOT GIVE YOU
A SPECIFIC NUMBER AT THIS TIME,
SENATOR. WE REALLY HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THE REGULATORY PROCESS
IN ORDER TO UNDERSTAND THE FULL
SCOPE OF THE COSTS. ALL RIGHT.
SENATOR HOBBS, SENATOR BECKER OR
SENATOR BECKER FIRST, THEN
SENATOR WAHAB. YEAH, THANKS. I
HAD A FEW SIMILAR QUESTIONS, BUT
I ONE OF THE WITNESSES PIQUED MY
INTEREST WHEN YOU TALKED ABOUT
CAL OSHA AND OUR STAFFING
COMPARED TO OTHER STATES. AND,
YOU KNOW, WE'VE TALKED IN A LOT
ABOUT THIS BILL AND POLICY
COMMITTEE ABOUT THE SAFETY
PIECES OF THIS. BUT THERE IS
OBVIOUSLY A FINANCIAL ASPECT TO
THE CAL OSHA HIRING. SO COULD
YOU JUST WALK US THROUGH AGAIN,
HOW IS THE CAL OSHA HIRING GOING
NOW? AND WHAT REALLY NEEDS TO
HAPPEN? WELL, THANKS FOR THE
SENATOR QUESTION. SENATOR AND
SENATOR SKINNER HIT ON IT A BIT
IN HER BACK AND FORTH WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THERE'S
BEEN ACTION HERE AT THE
LEGISLATURE TO CREATE, YOU KNOW,
PIS FOR CAL OSHA. WHAT I'M TO
UNDERSTAND IS, I MEAN, THIS IS A
PROBLEM THAT PREDATES GOVERNOR
NEWSOM. GOVERNOR BROWN, IT'S
BEEN HAPPENING FOR A WHILE. YOU
KNOW, THESE ARE CERTIFICATED
PROFESSIONAL WORKERS, INDUSTRIAL
HYGIENISTS, SAFETY ENGINEERS.
AND IT'S HARDER FOR THE STATE TO
COMPETE ON SALARY. SO I, I
BELIEVE I'M NOT INSINUATING
TODAY THAT THERE'S NO ATTEMPTS
TO HIRE THAT THE HIRING IS NOT
HAPPENING. IT'S JUST THERE ISN'T
ENOUGH PEOPLE HIRED. AND PART OF
THE REASON IS THE COMPETITIVE
NATURE OF THE SALARIES. AND JUST
ATTRACTING PEOPLE TO COME WORK
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA,
THAT DOESN'T ABSOLVE THE STATE
ENTIRELY. I THINK THAT, YOU
KNOW, UNDER A PREVIOUS DIRECTOR
OF DIR, THERE WAS SOME HIRING
ISSUES, SOME NEPOTISM, PERHAPS,
AND CAL HR HAD TO GET INVOLVED.
AND I THINK THERE'S BEEN SOME
HURDLES, INADVERTENT HURDLES PUT
UP, MAKING IT EVEN HARDER TO
HIRE A CAL. I MEAN, I DON'T WANT
TO GET IN THE WEEDS TODAY. THIS
IS PROBABLY THE FORUM FOR THAT.
BUT I LOOK FORWARD TO TALKING TO
ALL OF YOU IN THE SPRING ABOUT
THIS SOME MORE. BUT THE FACT OF
THE MATTER IS, THERE ARE NOT
ENOUGH PEOPLE THERE AT CAL OSHA
TO ENSURE THE SAFETY OF ANY
WORKPLACE IN THE STATE, LET
ALONE THESE REFINERY SITUATIONS
WHERE THERE ARE EVEN MORE
DANGEROUS THAN YOUR AVERAGE
WORKPLACE. YEAH, WELL, I
APPRECIATE THAT. IT'S ALWAYS
FRUSTRATING FOR ME WHEN WE HAVE
THESE VACANCIES AND WE AND WE,
AS YOU SAY, PUT UP EVEN MORE
ROADBLOCKS TO HIRING PEOPLE. AND
I JUST NEED TO MAKE SURE, YOU
KNOW, WHEN WE'RE DISCUSSING THE
FISCAL ASPECT OF THIS BILL,
WE'RE THINKING ABOUT THAT GOING
FORWARD, BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY WE
NEED THESE PEOPLE IN OTHER
AREAS. AS YOU SAY, BUT
ESPECIALLY IN THIS AREA. AND WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
BUDGETING FOR THAT AND THAT WE
EXERCISE OUR OVERSIGHT ROLE TO
MAKE SURE THOSE PEOPLE ARE
ACTUALLY HIRED. SO THANK YOU FOR
THAT. SENATOR WAHAB, THANK YOU.
I WILL SAY THIS ENTIRE PROCESS
HAS BEEN VERY FRUSTRATING FOR
MANY PEOPLE, INCLUDING IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE AVERAGE
PERSON. I DO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
IF, YOU KNOW, WE CONSTANTLY TALK
ABOUT CALIFORNIA'S BLEND, RIGHT?
CALIFORNIA HAS A VERY UNIQUE
BLEND. AND IN THE REPORT HERE,
IT ALSO STATES THAT WE HAVE
REFINERS SHUTTING DOWN OF THE,
YOU KNOW, HANDFUL OF REFINERS,
THE REFINERIES THAT WE HAVE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA, ROUGHLY
ABOUT NINE REFINERIES. WHAT ARE
WE DOING IN REGARDS TO INCREASE
THAT PARTICULAR NUMBER OR
POTENTIALLY EVEN CREATE SOME
MORE COMPETITION TO SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS? ZACH, YOU
WHO ARE YOU DIRECTING YOUR
QUESTION TO? OKAY,
REPRESENTATIVE FROM WHISPER YOU
CAN ANSWER APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION. SENATOR. I THINK WE'VE
SEEN THE NUMBER OF REFINERIES
DWINDLE OVER THE PAST 30 YEARS.
IN THE 80S, WE HAD OVER 40
REFINERIES. THAT'S A LOT OF
REDUNDANCY, A LOT OF RESILIENCY
IN THE SYSTEM WE ARE NOW. WE
JUST HAD TO CONVERT TO RENEWABLE
DIESEL, WHICH IS A SUCCESS STORY
OF THE LOW CARBON FUEL STANDARD
PROGRAM. BUT THEY ARE NO LONGER
PRODUCING CARBON GASOLINE. SO WE
ARE DOWN TO NINE, REALLY EIGHT
REFINERIES, MAJOR REFINERIES
PRODUCING THE GASOLINE THAT THIS
STATE NEEDS. I THINK FOR US, OUR
CONCERN IS THE YEAR AFTER YEAR
OF BILL, AFTER BILL THAT ISN'T
CONTEMPLATING THAT TRANSITION.
AND THE ACTUAL DEMAND IN
CALIFORNIA. THERE IS THIS SHIFT
TO ELECTRIC VEHICLES, WHICH, YOU
KNOW, IS IMPORTANT. THERE'S
MERIT TO IT. BUT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS JUST ISN'T
THERE. I THINK THE CEC PROJECTS
THAT THEY NEED A MILLION
CHARGING STATIONS BY THE YEAR
2030. TO YOU KNOW, GIVE
CONSUMERS, YOU KNOW, THE COMFORT
THAT THERE IS CHARGING THERE AT
100,000 CHARGING STATIONS AS OF
THIS YEAR. AND I THINK THE
BIGGER PICTURE IS WE ARE
STEERING AWAY FROM THE
APPROPRIATE CHARGE AND
JURISDICTION. THIS IS NOT THE
POLICY COMMITTEE. I WILL REMIND
MEMBERS AGAIN NOT TO. I'M NOT.
YOU MAY CONTINUE WITH YOUR
QUESTIONS, BUT WE NEED TO STICK
TO THE QUESTIONS THAT ARE THE
ASSESSMENT. SO IT'S VERY
SPECIFIC IN THE SENSE OF WHAT IS
THE INDUSTRY DOING TO ENSURE
THAT COSTS ARE LOW FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE SUPPLIES.
YOU KNOW, WE SPEAK OF
REDUNDANCY. AND I WANT TO BE
VERY CLEAR TO THE LARGER PUBLIC
WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
PARTICULAR SUPPLIES AND
POTENTIAL RESERVES, IT IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO BE ABLE
TO PIVOT VERY QUICKLY WHEN THERE
IS A SITUATION, YOU KNOW,
WHETHER IT'S IN THE MIDDLE EAST
OR SOMEWHERE ELSE, AND OUR
SUPPLY LINES ARE OBVIOUSLY
IMPACTED. SO MY QUESTION AGAIN
STILL COMES BACK TO THE SUPPLY
LINES IS WHY IS THIS SOMETHING
CONSIDERED NEGATIVE BY THE
INDUSTRY? I THINK FOR THE
PARTICULAR PROPOSAL, WE THINK IT
CREATES A PINCH POINT IN THE
REFINING PROCESS THAT IF YOU'RE
NOT ABLE TO FILL UP YOUR TANKS
BECAUSE YOU ARE NOW REQUIRED TO
HAVE A MINIMUM INVENTORY THAT
THE PRODUCTION COMING OFF OF
YOUR REFINERY IS GOING TO HAVE
TO SLOW DOWN BECAUSE YOUR TANKS
ARE ALREADY FULL. SO WE SEE IT
AS AN IMPACT TO NOT ONLY OUR OUR
OPERATIONS, BUT TO THE MARKET
ITSELF, TO CONSUMERS. BECAUSE IF
THAT FUEL ISN'T ABLE TO GET OUT,
THEN THERE'S GOING TO BE
POTENTIAL FUEL DISRUPTION. I
THINK AS IT RELATES TO WHAT ARE
WE DOING AS AN INDUSTRY TO
INCREASE SUPPLIES, INCREASE
REDUNDANCY? I THINK FIRST AND
FOREMOST, WE'VE BEEN ADVOCATING
FOR MORE SUPPLY, MORE, MORE, YOU
KNOW, ABILITY TO PRODUCE THE
ENERGY WE NEED IN THE STATE AND
NOT RELY ON IMPORT STRATEGIES
THAT IS BEING CONTEMPLATED IN
THE CARB SCOPING PLAN. WE THINK
REFINERIES STAYING IN THE STATE
IS IMPORTANT. WE THINK
PRODUCTION IN THE STATE IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THE
BOTTLENECKS AT THE PORT ARE
REAL. BUT ISN'T THIS BILL DOING
EXACTLY THAT? NØ I THINK THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF FACTORS OUTSIDE
OF THIS BILL THAT IMPACT SUPPLY,
PRODUCTION. WE HAVE A SEPARATE
REGULATOR FOR PRODUCTION THAT WE
ARE NOT RECEIVING PERMITS TO
DRILL THAT IMPACTS SUPPLY. WE
HAVE PORT CONSTRAINTS THAT IS
IMPACTING BLENDING COMPONENTS,
FINISHED GASOLINE, CRUDE OIL
FROM COMING IN TO CALIFORNIA.
THOSE ARE OUTSIDE OF THIS BILL.
THIS BILL IS VERY SPECIFIC TO
REFINERIES, NOT THE OTHER MARKET
PLAYERS IN THE SYSTEM LIKE
WHOLESALERS, DISTRIBUTORS,
ENERGY TRADERS. THIS IS JUST
LOOKING AT REFINERIES. OKAY. AND
THEN TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE, I JUST WANT TO BE VERY
CLEAR. THIS IS TO DIRECT THE CDC
TO DEVELOP REQUIREMENTS ON
REFINERS TO MAINTAIN SUPPLY
PLANS TO COVER PRODUCTION LOSS
DURING MAINTENANCE EVENTS AND
MAINTAIN MINIMUM LEVELS OF
SUPPLY INVENTORIES. CORRECT?
CORRECT. OKAY. AND YOU BELIEVE
THAT THIS WOULD SUPPORT IF THERE
IS A DISRUPTION TO THE SUPPLY
CHAIN, AS WE'VE SEEN DURING THE
PANDEMIC, AS WE HAVE SEEN
MULTIPLE OTHER TIMES, THAT THIS
WOULD POTENTIALLY BENEFIT NOT
ONLY THE STATE BUT ALSO
CONSUMERS. SENATOR, I BELIEVE
THAT'S MORE OF A POLICY FOCUSED
QUESTION. FINANCE IS HERE JUST
TO PROVIDE ESTIMATES OF A STATE
LEVEL IMPLEMENTATION FOR CDC AND
THE COST RELATED TO CDC FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT ASSEMBLY.
MEMBER. YES, SENATOR.
SPECIFICALLY TO YOUR QUESTION
ABOUT WHY THIS APPLIES JUST TO
REFINERIES, BECAUSE THIS BILL IS
AIMED SPECIFICALLY AT THAT
PROBLEM OF SUPPLY CONSTRAINTS
THAT OCCUR DURING MAINTENANCE
EVENTS. IT'S NOT INTENDED TO
SOLVE ALL OF THE GASOLINE PRICE
SPIKE PROBLEMS THAT COME UP WHEN
SUPPLIES ARE LIMITED BECAUSE OF
INTERNATIONAL EVENTS. THIS IS
DESIGNED SPECIFICALLY TO ASK THE
CDC TO CREATE RULEMAKING, TO
WORK WITH THE INDUSTRY, TO TRY
AND INCREMENTALLY INCREASE THE
AVAILABLE INVENTORY AT
REFINERIES, SO THAT WHEN THERE
IS AN ISSUE OF CONSTRAINT IN
SUPPLY BECAUSE OF MAINTENANCE
EVENTS, WE HAVE RESILIENCY IN
THE SYSTEM THAT WILL PROTECT
CONSUMERS. THERE IS A THERE HAS
BEEN HISTORICALLY A $2 BILLION
COST TO CONSUMERS WHEN THAT
SPECIFIC EVENT OCCURS. AND THIS
LEGISLATION IS AIMED TO TRY TO
PREVENT THAT FROM HAPPENING TO
PROTECT CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS
WORKING COLLABORATIVELY WITH THE
INDUSTRY, IDENTIFYING THE
STORAGE CAPACITY THAT THEY HAVE
IN EXISTENCE NOW, BECAUSE
SEASONALLY THAT SUPPLY IS
AVAILABLE AT DIFFERENT TIMES OF
THE YEAR, IT DWINDLES DURING THE
SUMMER MONTHS TO A PLACE WHERE
IT IS TIGHT, AND THE IDEA IS TO
WORK REFINERY BY REFINERY TO
FIND A WAY TO INCREASE THAT
SUPPLY INCREMENTALLY AND PREVENT
THAT SPIKE FROM OCCURRING. AND
CAN I HAVE THE INDIVIDUAL FROM
THE CDC ALSO RESPOND TO THE SAME
QUESTION? CÁC. THANK YOU.
SENATOR. I THINK I JUST AGREE
WITH WHAT THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SHARED. I THINK, AGAIN, THE
OVERALL POINT HERE FOR US IS
WORKING THROUGH IN PARTNERSHIP
AND COLLABORATION WITH THE
INDUSTRY AND THROUGH THE
CONSTRAINTS AND ALL OF THE
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS, INCLUDING
THE WORKFORCE AND LABOR, TO
FIGURE OUT. AGAIN, I THINK THE
WAY WE WOULD ARTICULATE THIS IS,
YOU KNOW, AS WE PREPLAN GOING
INTO A SUMMER WITH THE INDUSTRY
AND COLLABORATE WITH THEM, WHAT
EFFICIENCIES CAN WE GAIN AHEAD
IN PRE-PLANNING, INCLUDING
IMPROVING OUR INVENTORY LEVELS
TO REDUCE THE DOWNSTREAM
REACTIVE BEHAVIOR IN THE SPOT
MARKET, WHICH REALLY DRIVES UP
THE PRICES? SO THAT'S WHAT WE'LL
BE FOCUSING ON AS A PART OF THE
RULEMAKING PROCESS. AND FOR THE
CDC, YOU GUYS ARE INTERESTED IN
THE END GOAL, AT LEAST FOR ME,
WHICH IS THE CONSUMER PRICE. YES,
THAT THAT WOULD BE OUR SOLE
FOCUS, ENSURING THAT IT'S
REDUCED. CORRECT? YES. OVERALL.
OKAY. SO I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THIS. AND I DO WANT TO JUST
HIGHLIGHT THAT THIS IS A
DIFFICULT BILL. I AM I AM
DISAPPOINTED THAT WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH INFORMATION REGARDING THE
COST FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ON A NUMBER OF THINGS,
AS WELL AS THE LONG TERM
PLANNING OF WHAT DOES THIS
REALLY LOOK LIKE? BUT FOR ME,
FOR CALIFORNIANS, VERY MUCH THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING IS ENSURING
THAT WE HAVE MINIMAL LEVELS OF
SUPPLY INVENTORY AS WELL AS SOME
TYPE OF BACKUP PLAN WHEN PRICE
SPIKES HAPPEN OR THERE IS SOME
NEGATIVE EFFECT TO OUR SUPPLY
CHAIN. SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. IN A MOMENT I WILL
ASK YOU TO CLOSE. I WILL JUST
POINT OUT THAT IT HAS BEEN
BROUGHT UP. AND THIS IS
LEGITIMATE, THAT THE STATE DOES
PURCHASE GASOLINE. SO IF THERE
ARE IMPACTS OF CAUSING GASOLINE
PRICES TO GO UP DUE TO THIS
BILL, THAT IS A LEGITIMATE
ASSESSMENT. HOWEVER, I WOULD
NOTE ON PAGE FIVE OF THE
ANALYSIS HOW IT SHOWS THAT THE
BILL IS CONSTRUCTED TO PROHIBIT
THE CEC FROM ADOPTING A
REGULATION UNLESS IT DETERMINES
THAT THE LIKELY BENEFIT TO
CONSUMERS AVOIDING PRICE
VOLATILITY OUTWEIGH THE
POTENTIAL COSTS TO CONSUMERS AND
IN THIS CASE, THE COST. THE
CONSUMER IS ALSO AT THE STATE.
SO I JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE
REMIND US THAT THAT IS A
COMPONENT IN THE BILL. AND OF
COURSE, YES, BY AUTHORIZING IT,
WE ARE ENTRUSTING THE CEC AND
THE DIVISION TO FOLLOW IT. AND
IT WILL BE ON THE LEGISLATURE TO
PROVIDE THE OVERSIGHT IF THEY DO
NOT FOLLOW IT. BUT AS HAS BEEN
POINTED OUT SO FAR, THIS BILL IS
NOT ITS FOCUS, IS NOT TO ADDRESS
ANY. AND EVERY CIRCUMSTANCE THAT
CAUSES GASOLINE PRICES TO GO UP
IN CALIFORNIA, BUT PURELY AND
SOLELY THOSE ASPECTS OF OUR THAT
ARE WE COULD SAY, THOUGH, WE
COULD SAY ARE MORE WITHIN OUR
CONTROL AND THE EXTERNAL THINGS
OF MIDDLE EAST CRISES AND
UKRAINIAN WARS AND SUCH LIKE
THAT ARE NOT IN OUR CONTROL
ANYWAY. SO SEEING NO ONE ELSE ON
THE DAIS WILL ALLOW OUR AUTHORS
TO CLOSE AND THEN TAKE A MOTION
NÓ. OKAY, THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE AND MEMBERS FOR
HEARING AB TWO ONE TODAY. THIS
IS THE 19TH AND I THINK THE 20TH
HOUR OF HEARINGS THAT WE HAVE
HAD ON THIS LEGISLATION. AND I
APPRECIATE EVERYBODY'S
PARTICIPATION AND CONTRIBUTION
TO THE DISCUSSION AS WE CONTINUE
TO WORK ON MEETING OUR STATE'S
AMBITIOUS CLIMATE GOALS AND
TRANSITION TO A CLEAN ENERGY
ECONOMY, GASOLINE IS STILL
NEEDED TO FUEL CARS THAT HAVE AN
INTERNAL COMBUSTION ENGINE. THIS
PROPOSAL IS A COMMON SENSE
MEASURE TO PROVIDE RELIEF FOR
CONSUMERS WHO RELY ON GASOLINE
TO DRIVE THEIR VEHICLES TO WORK,
AND CHILDREN TO SCHOOL. I
RESPECTFULLY URGE, AND I VOTE
FOR THE BILL. ALL RIGHT, SO THE
MOTION IS WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR WAHAB, THE MOTION IS DUE
PASS. AND IF WE COULD DO A ROLL
CALL. SKINNER. AYE. SKINNER. AYE.
JONES. NO. JONES. NO. ASHBY. HI.
ASHBY. AYE. BECKER. BECKER. AYE.
BRADFORD. CIERTO. NO. CIERTO.
NO. WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE. 4 TO 2.
IS THAT ADEQUATE FOR PASSAGE?
OKAY. THE BILL PASSES. THAT'S ON
A 4 TO 2 VOTE. AND THANK YOU.
WITH THAT THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WILL
ADJOURN NEXT.